from the Fox and Friends Weekend crew
Merry Christmas to the five and we have
a very special Christmas performance for
you a gift if you will from Fox and
Friends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we are so grateful that the Yuletide
carolers are helping us get in the mood
it is almost time to light the
All-American Christmas tree and joining
us to do that are heroes from the NYPD
and the FDNY these selfless honorees put
their lives on the line every day to
keep us safe with us tonight are members
of the nypd's precinct 32 in January
they lost detectives Jason Rivera and
Wilbert Mora in an ambush attack and
from the FDNY our members from EMS
station 49. in September Lieutenant
Allison Russo Ellinger was senselessly
killed after being stabbed in a random
assault
with us representing the FDNY is FDNY
assistant chief Mike Aiello
Mike we want to thank the airport the uh
the fire department in New York City for
all the work that you do and you know
people don't think about it that much
but every time you respond there is a
burning building a burning house and
every time your life is in danger yeah
sure judge thank you so much for having
us it's only fitting that when we begin
the season of joy that we pause for a
minute and recognize those people we
lost last year okay so we lost uh
Captain Allison Russo we lost
firefighter Timmy Klein we lost fire
fighter Jesse Gerhart all three members
tragically killed in the line of duty
all three members epitomize dedication
and service and our department will
never forget their sacrifice yes and
neither will New Yorkers we thank each
and every one of you for all the work
you do every day for all of us God bless
you yeah thank you and representing the
NYPD is inspector Amira yakitelli
inspector that is a great great title so
I gotta ask you how how are the police
doing how are they doing we always worry
about us how about them
the police are doing great because uh
you know what makes the city so great is
uh the relationship between the NYPD and
the community and events like this tree
lighting tonight oh what helped us
strengthen that partnership between us
and the communities we serve
it is a privilege to be able to
represent the men and women of the NYPD
here tonight
as we honor and remember the sacrifices
made by our fallen heroes detective
Jason Rivera and Wilbur Mora we miss you
immensely
and we will we work hard every day to
carry on your incredible Legacy today
and every day
to all the family friends and co-workers
and all of New York and the rest of
America merry Christmas and happy
holidays thank you
and to light the tree in just a moment
awesome thank you and we're so excited
to have Fox anchors and employees kids
here this is my daughter Cleo Jesse Jr
over there with his dad this is Jesse Jr
and the judge you brought Stella right
there in all her pinkness and all the
kids come on guys and there's a JJ and
wave JJ wave to everybody can you wave
yay well we have an extra special
surprise for all of you I've been
telling you about it look over at the
fire
Santa is here hello Santa
Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas are we
ready everybody let's light the
All-American tree right now in Chicken
nine Merry Christmas eight seven six
five four three two one
[Applause]
hi
Merry Christmas
[Applause]
good good I got I got some candy canes
for you
for Christmas oh he's giving out a
little treat you wanna you want some
candy we'll see you ready yeah I can't
promise you
I gotta check that list again you never
know
thank you so much Merry Christmas you're
a unicorn all right that's it for us
thanks everybody for coming out to the
All-American tree lighting at Fox Square
merry Christmas happy holidays hi winner
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now